A very different approach is to
give up on the goal of running
unmodified operating systems.
Instead, the primary goal is to
offer a virtualization solution that
offers performance and avoids some of
the overheads that may be associated
with any of the complexities that are
necessary to support unmodified guests.
In contrast to full virtualization,
this is called paravirtualization.
With paravirtualization,
the guest OS is modified so
that it now knows that it's running
in a virtualized environment
on top of a hypervisor as opposed to
on top of native physical resources.
A paravirtualized guest OS will
not necessarily try to directly
perform operations,
which it knows that they will fail.
And instead, it will make explicit
calls to the hypervisor to
request the desired behavior.
Or specifically,
the desired hardware manipulations.
These calls to the hypervisor
are called hypercalls.
And they behave in a way that's
similar to the way system calls behave
in an operating system.
So the unprivileged guest
OS here that's modified
will package all relevant information
about its context, its current state.
And it will specify
the desired hypercall.
And at that point,
it will issue the hypercall and
that will trap to
the virtual machine monitor.
When the hypervisor
completes the operation,
control will be pass back to the virtual
machine, to the guest, and any data,
if appropriate,
will be made available to it.
This approach of paravirtualization
was originally adapted and
popularized by the Xen hypervisor.
This was a popular
virtualization solution and
originally was an open source
hypervisor that started
as a research project at
University of Cambridge in the UK.
This was later commercialized
as XenSource and
XenSource is now owned by Citrix.
But there still remains a lot of
activity in the open source Xen project,
including at our own
research group here.
One thing to note, however, is that
the open source Xen version as, and
the Citrix Xen version have diverged
perhaps substantially over time